hello everyone welcome to the line
focused channel and my name is Paul
today we'll be answering the question
how are British English and American
English different one of the most
commonly asked questions by learners of
English and hopefully native speakers of
English will learn a thing or two from
this video as well the truth is that
both British English and American
English have numerous varieties in other
words various accents and dialects so
for the main part of this video I'll try
to focus on the most standard non
regional variety of each one disclaimer
I'm not American I'm actually Canadian
but I'm confident that we will someday
be Americans after the invasion standard
Canadian English is very very close to
general American English so I will say
the American English samples myself
unless there's some specific need to
distinguish between American and
Canadian pronunciation there are several
ways in which British English and
American English are different
vocabulary accent spelling and grammar
vocabulary let me just throw a bunch of
examples at you in the US people
generally say garbage or trash while in
the UK they generally say rubbish both
literally and figuratively
the game was rubbish Americans go on
vacation while Brits go on holiday and
that's also possible in American English
in the u.s. people rent apartments while
in the UK they rent flats in the US if
your apartment is at street level then
you live on the first floor and the
person above you lives on the second
floor in the UK you live on the ground
floor and the person above you lives on
the first floor if that person above you
is unable or just too lazy to take the
stairs in the u.s. they take the
elevator in the UK they take the lift
when you're bored at home in the US you
might turn on the TV while in the UK you
would turn on the telly when you step
outside of your building to go for a
walk in the u.s. you might walk on the
sidewalk while in the UK you walk on the
pavement and if you're tired of walking
in the u.s. you might take the subway in
the UK you take the under
in the US it's perfectly okay to wear
pants when you're riding the subway but
in the UK you'd better wear some
trousers too because pants means
Underpants and specifically women's
Underpants are sometimes referred to as
knickers in the UK so when someone over
reacts to something in the u.s. you
might say don't get your panties in a
bunch but in the UK you would say don't
get your knickers in a twist
Paul how dare you be so crude now I
can't show this video to my six year old
students oh don't even worry about that
they'll just watch it on their phones
during recess going back to the word
pants for a moment it can also be used
in British English as an adjective
meaning something is crappy or it sucks
for example that's album is pants in
American English you might say that
album sucks accent so for the u.s. I'll
try to focus on general American English
and for the UK I'll try to focus on
received pronunciation these are the
accents you're likely to hear on CNN and
the BBC respectively our sounds American
English is Rohtak meaning that our
sounds are always clearly pronounced
British English is non-rhotic meaning
that the R sound is not pronounced
unless it's followed by a vowel sound
listen to the difference my father's in
the car my father's in the car let's
focus on two words father father
car car notice that the final R sound is
not pronounced in British English father
ends in a simple schwa vowel like father
and in car the vowel sound is lengthened
in place of the R sound car now the
thing about British non-rhotic accents
that I find pretty wild is something
called the intrusive R that means that
people sometimes add an R sound to a
word that doesn't actually have one if
it's followed by a vowel in the next
word for example in the sentence I saw a
film in British English it sometimes
sounds like this I saw a film so you can
hear that there's an R sound connecting
saw and ah I once had a British
on-the-job trainer and I remember she
said hello my name is Paula and I'll be
your trainer today I remember thinking
Paula what you can't say your own name
but it wasn't just her that was the
intrusive R T sounds
in British English and again I must
emphasize that I'm talking about the
accent referred to as received
pronunciation T sounds are pronounced as
hard T's in other words voiceless sounds
in the u.s. they sometimes sound like an
alveolar tap instead of to an alveolar
stop this normally occurs in an
unstressed syllable between two vowel
sounds or between a vowel and a rhotic
sound like an R sound so in the u.s.
people say butter in the UK they say
butter in the u.s. stop fighting in the
UK stop fighting you may have also
noticed that the O sound in the word
stop was a little different which brings
me to a sound in the word stop the
American Oh sound is an unwound Advani
show sound is rounded all another
example
hot-hot there's also the Oh diphthong in
the word no in the UK no in the UK the
sound is a schwa followed by an O as
input show show a sound
in other words sounds represented by the
letter A ah in UK English normally
becomes an AK sound in American English
for example in the UK half and in the US
half words with app in British English
remained pretty similar in American
English in the UK cat into the u.s. cat
an exception is a small set of words in
which the a is followed by a double are
in which case the vowel is pronounced as
a in the u.s. in the UK Mary in the US
Mary because of the difference in the
u.s. Mary and Mary sound the same carry
and carry sound the same spelling
American and British spellings are
largely the same but there are a few
notable differences this is in large
part because Noah Webster whom the
Webster dictionary is named after made
an effort to reform English spelling in
the 1700s in order to make the words
spelled the way they sounded this
resulted in some spelling changes in
American English most but not all words
that end in re in the UK and then ER in
the US for example sent
Theater meter somber some words that end
in NCE in the UK are spelled with NSE in
the US licensed defense offense some
words with o you in the UK are spelled
with O in the u.s. color favor honor
labor etc the ending is II became ize in
the US organize apologize a similar
change also occurs in other contexts
where the S is voiced in other words it
makes a sound analyze cosy there are
verbs ending with L that take a double
vowel in British English when a suffix
is added in American English there's no
double L traveled cancelled marvelous if
you're wondering how the last one fits
in with the others remember that Marvel
is a verb and then an adjective all
suffix is added to it grammar there are
only very minor grammatical differences
between British English and American
English auxiliary verbs British people
use shall for the future much more than
Americans as well as to ask for advice
or an opinion some difference in
preposition use in the u.s. people say
on the weekend but in the UK they say at
the weekend and in the US people say
different from or different them but in
the UK they say different from or
different too there are some different
past tense forms for example in American
English the past tense of the word learn
is learned while in British English it's
more common to say it learnt actually
both forms are used in either country
but there is more of a tendency towards
one form this is true for other words
like dreamed vs. dreamt burned vs. burnt
leaned vs. linked etc another example in
the US the past tense of dive is usually
dove in the UK it's dived may be the
American form developed by analogy with
drive and drove anyways differences like
these are not consistent but you'll
notice some different past tense forms
here and their past participles
sometimes past participles have a
different form the most well-known
example is for the verb get in the US
there's get got gotten but in the UK yet
get
got got both forms got and gotten have
existed since the Middle English period
but gotten has fallen out of use in the
UK God can be used in American English
in the form have got but with the
meaning of have not have received or
have become I haven't gotten the
eviction notice yet I haven't got the
eviction notice yet alright let's check
a couple more sentences and see what we
encounter in the US I think we need a
lawyer in the UK I reckon we need a
solicitor you'll notice that a couple of
words here are different British people
often use the word reckon which means
think or suppose Americans know this
word but rarely use it and while
Americans would typically refer to a
professional legal consultant as a
lawyer in the UK they often say
solicitor which is a type of lawyer that
does consultation the type of lawyer who
represents you in court in the UK is
usually a barrister while in the u.s.
they're usually referred to as attorneys
another sentence in the u.s. I'm going
for a beer with my friends in the UK I'm
going for a pint with my mates notice
that British people often say pints
where Americans would say beer Brits
also say beer as a countable noun like
this but pint is frequently used and
notice that Brits often say mate where
Americans would say friend the
differences between British English and
American English might seem surprising
or amusing but remember in this video
I'm sooo mning in on the differences and
focusing on them for the most part
they're actually the same there are some
minor differences in vocabulary and
pronunciation and grammar and in
spelling but any native speaker with a
little bit of exposure to the other will
quickly adapt to these differences and
be able to understand the other variety
without any problem the differences are
sometimes greater if we focus on
regional dialects and so she elects of
British English and American English
while most Americans probably have no
trouble understanding received
pronunciation they may have some trouble
understanding cockney English or the
Geordie accent of northeastern England
or other varieties but as far as
standard non-regional speech goes i'd
say that the differences are minimal
however learners of English who focus on
one of the two varieties will likely
have a little bit of trouble
understanding the other until the
gain significant exposure to it the
question of the day what other
differences between American and British
English are you aware of in this video I
was only able to give a limited number
of examples so add yours in the comments
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again thank you to all of my wonderful
patreon supporters and these ones right
here on the screen are my top two you're
patreon supporters so many extra special
thanks to them and to everyone out there
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]